the only purpose of food is to get olive
oil into your mouth there are three
long-lived Societies in the blue zones
that use a liter of olive oil per wheat
that's about 12 to 14 tablespoons a day
if you're going to have a steak please
pour it on your meat as they do in Italy
they always bring a bottle of olive oil
so you can have steak Florentina and
just drench it with olive oil the steak
is there to get olive oil into your
mouth broccoli is there to get olive oil
into your mouth there are wonderful
cruciferous vegetables the purpose of
the sweet potato is to get olive oil
into your mouth things like Yuca or
Yucca make phenomenal french fries but
parboil them first and then put them in
the airfryer so get some guacamole
believe it or not true guacamole does
not have tomatoes in it that's an
American whatever and get yourself some
jicama sticks Trader Joe's has them lots
of plain old grocery stores to have them
use that as your dipping chip vegetables
in The Chicory family the more chicory
you can get in your life Radicchio the
kind Italian red lettuce is pure inulin
and you've got bugs below it for you hey
it's Evan Carmichael and I make these
videos because the thing that saved me
as an entrepreneur was watching the
stories of other successful
entrepreneurs and I learned from their
advice I learned from their motivation
and honestly I have no idea where I
would be if I didn't have those videos
to inspire me I still need them for
myself today too and I hope that they
can inspire you as well so today let's
invest in our health together and get
some expert advice on our health and
nutrition
rule number two is learn to eat
intuitively with Sal di Stefano there
was something in the book that you
talked about that when the chapter
heading came across I was like no Sal
come on you know better than this and by
the end of the chapter I was like oh my
God he's right intuitive eating yeah and
I respond violently yeah or I did before
reading your book how about that I
respond violently to the idea that
people should eat uh intuitively and
then I realized by your description it
is exactly what people should be doing
so how do people get there yeah so the
reason why in when people hear the term
intuitive eating there's uh usually a
violent response or like that that can
never work is because if your intuition
is based off of limited or no
information you don't know what you
don't know
and off the fact that you've learned
your whole life to Value food for its
palatability well now your intuitive
eating is based off of that so people
think well if I ate intuitively I'll
just eat donuts and pizza all day long
well yeah because that's what we're
starting so you can't go from where
you're at now to I'm just gonna
intuitively do this as if there's like
this magical ether I'm going to reach up
and grab the answers it doesn't work
that way we have to move into different
stages of learning before we get to that
point so there's this has been talked
about in many other uh Arenas and I like
to communicate this because it applies
so well here there's four stages of
learning with anything that you go to
learn the first stage is uh your your
unconsciously incompetent so you don't
know what you don't know you get into
something for the first time you want to
go learn how to ride a skateboard or you
want to learn how to do art or play an
instrument you don't know what you don't
know because you have no idea so then
you get in there and then you move
pretty quickly to the next stage which
is I'm consciously incompetent okay all
this stuff like I don't know any of it
but I'm aware that I don't know any of
these things that I had no you know
awareness of before right the third
stage is conscious competence that's
where you have to consciously think and
act in a way that makes you competent so
I have to consciously okay I need this
much protein okay this food has you know
this these carbohydrates these fats
here's where my calories are this is
going to make me feel this way this is
going to improve my performance okay I'm
stressed I tend to want to eat this way
when I'm stressed so you're in that
conscious competent stage but if you do
that long enough
and you practice long enough then you
move to the intuitive stage which is
unconscious competence okay so if you
ever watch a kid learn how to walk you
can clearly see them go through these
different stages you know if they're
unconsciously incompetent then they're
consciously income then they're
consciously confident and a kid has to
think about every step and you know now
I walk now I don't think about walking
it just happens right that's the stage
where intuitive eating
um is now how do I get there
well first you have to identify all of
the values
around food all of them and we're we're
only really aware of a couple or maybe
just one how good does this taste has it
and how enjoyable is it in fact
most people
most people in modern societies have
never really felt hungry we have it's
insane you know hunger kicks in like 48
to 72 hours with no food how many people
have gone 48 to 72 hours and it wasn't a
medical emergency without food so what
we connect hunger to is actually
Cravings Cravings are very different
than hunger Cravings are not attached to
my body needs nutrients and needs
calories Cravings are attached to
emotions
feelings uh my environment am I stressed
am I anxious am I happy am I sad is it
the movies am I at a birthday party am I
having fun with my friends right that's
Cravings that's not hunger so we have to
identify
or or decipher between the two we also
have to understand all of the other
values around food and appreciate them
and the fitness space does a terrible
job with this the fitness space
communicates food very from a very
mechanistic point of view proteins fats
calories carbs eat this to get this
result as if we're robots like here's
your meal plan I used to do this as an
early trainer oh you want to lose 30
pounds no problem here's your meal plan
and then you'll do great and then for
some reason nobody's ever able to stick
to it as if we're not complex emotional
behavior-based creatures right so what
are the values around food well we've
already identified the palatability
that's an actual value there's nothing
wrong with that enjoying food for the
sake of its how it makes you feel as a
real value
there's also how does it fuel my body
so physically how does this affect my
body there's also connecting with people
if you've ever cooked a meal with your
spouse or hung out with friends you
haven't seen in a while and had a maybe
a a dish that you guys enjoyed when
you're in college or whatever you know
what that's all about there's also
can it help me escape or distract myself
what's my relationship to food and then
you also want to look at impulsive
behaviors we all have behaviors that
operate just under awareness that tend
to be impulsive and identifying those is
key to being able to eat intuitively
effectively once you identify those
impulses and create space between you
and the action then you can change how
you react to how do you create that
space so one what is an impulse meaning
like I go for ice cream or you go for
chips yes that's what we're talking
about yeah so
um everybody has that trigger food right
for me it is chips I like potato chips
are my absolute favorite and my trigger
is is boredom if I have nothing to do
then I'll reach for this distraction of
this food that you know whatever so I've
identified that and so one thing that I
did for myself here's here's a strategy
that I've taught a lot of clients to do
is I'll say Okay first off don't tell
yourself you can't have something
like I understand the sentiment and I
get the validity in that like I I can't
have this food because it's bad for me I
get that but our psychology doesn't work
very well with that extremely
disciplined people can do that most
people are not that way though so you
can say I'll have it I just got to drive
to the grocery store and get myself a
single serving bag and all that does I
mean the grocery store is only a mile
and a half from my house all it does is
it creates space between me and the
action so the impulse kicks in I want
those chips I'll drive the store I put
my shoes you'll actually let yourself do
that I will but usually I don't right
I'll let myself but nine out of ten
times I'll be like yeah
I want it but not that bad yeah and then
I'll deal and I'll have that space in
between me and that impulse but all
those things that I identified those all
have value and all of them can
contribute to an improved quality of
life and health rule number three is get
enough omega-3 fatty acids with Sean
Stevenson this is so freaking important
if anybody does anything from this
episode I want to make sure that you're
getting in enough omega-3 fatty acids in
the form of DHA and EPA so
number one
DHA and EPA have expressed Lanes if you
want to think about the blood-brain
barrier being like a toll booth they
have Express passes to get into the
brain like your brain sucks them up like
in droves because they're needed for
structure of your brain cells
Omega-3s function as structural fats in
your brain creating plasticity
creating stability and signal
transduction so your brain cells can
actually talk to each other
without Omega-3s goes wrong real fast to
the degree one of the craziest studies
in the book they found that the folks
who had the lowest intake of DHA and EPA
had the highest rate of brain shrinkage
all right your your brain literally
shrinks rapidly if you're not getting
these fats in and so what it was was
just under 1.2 teaspoons a day anything
under that
increase the rate of brain shrinkage
what are the best three foods or
supplements to get your um
DHA and EPA
food first the general neurology found
that folks who consume Just One Seafood
meal per week do in fact perform better
on cognitive skills tests I think that's
a direct one-to-one response to those
Omega-3s but if you if you're not taking
uh if you're taking a vegan or
vegetarian protocol I've got news for
good news for you too but food first and
then of course there's grass-fed beef in
that same Spectrum has Omega-3s a high
ratio of Omega-3s uh eggs the best food
source though Tom is not the fish the
fatty fish but the fatty fish eggs so
salmon Roe and caviar can have three
times more DHA and EPA than the fish
itself and then we've got from there
most of the studies done on DHA and EPA
is done via fish oil all right so I did
share some studies in the book that are
just really shocking when it comes
official but then from there the next
rung down is krill oil right Krill
that's the microscopic shrimp super
dense in astaxanthin which makes your
body absorb Omega-3s even better it's
incredible that might be for somebody
who's doing a vegetarian protocol
wherever that lies on your ethics krill
oil might be a savior for your brain if
anything everybody today even if you're
taking a vegan protocol please get
yourself an algae oil all right a high
quality algae oil it has the DHA and EPA
there but we don't have clinical studies
now to see its Effectiveness but we do
know that it's there and I just don't
want you to wait around for that data
DHA is so important for your brain just
to be clear
this is the plant source is ala right
that's what you find in chia seeds and
flax seeds and hemp seeds I would have
patients get flaxseed oil for years I
was missing the point it's not the same
as DHA and EPA but it's so important for
your brain that your body can convert
some ala into DHA but you can lose
depending on your metabolism your unique
metabolic fingerprint you can lose 90 in
the conversion process and so you'll
have to eat
bags of chia seeds a day to get what
your brain needs you know it's just not
doable
and plus you probably want to leave the
bathroom at some point
um so that's that's that part and I also
want to share this really quickly with
uh Omega-3s and omega-6s this was a
study and this was published in the
journal nutrients and it found that a
large increase in the ratio of omega-6s
in the diet compared to Omega-3s
directly increases our risk of obesity
but here's the most important part
another study and
this was highlighted and then I broke
this down I'm getting giggy giddy right
now another study highlighted in each
marker found that an imbalance in
omega-6s to Omega-3s leads to
dysfunction of your hunger-related
hormones and increase fat storage even
with calories being the same
even with calories being the same people
with a higher intake of omega-6s gained
more weight
and more body fat and had more
dysfunction to their hunger related
hormones all right epic caloric
controller
Omega-3s help to reduce inflammation
omega-6s are not bad but we need more
Omega-3s right now because it could
become such a omega-6 dominant Society
rule number four is limit your processed
food intake with Dr Lane Norton if you
were going to make a broad stroke that
trying to focus on mentally processed
foods is very important
the one caveat I would say is I think
it's important to understand why because
otherwise people can make this weird
Association that like if I eat any
mentally or any processed food it's
going to kill me or like every time I
eat it it's like I'm smoking a cigarette
and my health you know my longevity is
declining
based on the studies we have
it's mostly about the energy that
processed food
just gets people to spontaneously eat
more and and Kevin Hull showed this in
his study that was very I mean he
designed some of the most elegant
studies in nutrition he's great and they
basically took people from a minimally
processed food diet and then gave them
access to ultra processed foods very few
instructions just eat till you feel
satisfied and they spontaneously
increase their calorie intake by 500
calories a day I mean that's that's
massive
so
there's so and we quite haven't quite
figured it out you know people said well
it's it's car it's sugar it doesn't
appear to be sugar in terms of just in
isolation uh well it's fats doesn't
appear to be fats and isolation well
it's the combination of sugar and fat
Hartley was the combination of sugar fat
and salt partly but there's some kind of
like overall magic to the texture and
the mouth feel and just the overall
palatability of stuff which is always
why I say there's like right and wrong
ways to these different diets like for
example like there's a right way to do
plant-based and then there's you know
like what's in some of these
documentaries where they're eating like
plant-based mac and cheese you know and
again I love a good mac and cheese but
like that should not form like that
should not be pitched as a healthy diet
just because it's plant-based right
because I mean you're eating a highly
processed food that's very palatable and
easy to overeat
same thing for keto you've now got like
keto ice creams and you've got you know
keto cookies and all these sorts of
things and I'm like yeah and if you look
at them they actually have more calories
than the normal stuff and I'm like yeah
this is completely missing the point
here like you're actually just taking
yourself like the whole point of those
diets is the reason you tend to lose
weight is originally like good luck you
know 10 years ago doing a keto diet
eating processed food right like you
just couldn't do it really
no you can but the problem is it's not
going to work because you're going to be
still consuming too many calories
because even though it's Keto what are
they doing well they're trying to make
it more palatable they're trying to make
a better mouth feel which I guess if
you're being keto for the sake of being
keto great but if there's if you have
hopes of body composition modification
uh it's gonna you know really negatively
impact so yes I think minimizing the
amount of processed food you consume can
be important also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all of the
Lessons Learned in this video as well as
pull out our three favorite learnings
and quotes that will inspire you to
actually do something the worksheet will
also give you space to write down what
your key takeaways are and your specific
plan of action to make sure you're
getting results if you want the
worksheet designed specifically for this
video absolutely for free there's a link
in the description below go click on it
and start building the momentum in your
life and your business I'll see you
there rule number 5 is eliminate
fructose with Dr David pullmutter a lot
of my work these days is taking the
fructose out of the human eye
I have
put myself in a place in very recent
years of focusing on the notion of
evolutionary environmental mismatch what
does it mean it means that our
environment and what we expose ourselves
to in the modern world in terms of food
in terms of other aspects of our
day-to-day existence is deeply in
contrast to what our genome would best
be served by we evolved over hundreds of
thousands of years under a fairly static
set of circumstances suddenly in the
blink of an eye those circumstances have
changed and our genome has not had a
chance to adapt so we are living with a
Paleolithic genome in a very very
industrialized type of environment and
there's this a huge mismatch and I
and I say that's become sort of my
watchword in terms of focus as of late
but I wrote a paper on this topic half a
century ago publishing it uh in the in
the Miami Herald our local newspaper
when I was 16 and I called uh at the end
of that uh missive uh the question uh
what about those of us living today with
the outdated Machinery being that we are
more suited to a different environment
so we're not going to change part one
The evolutionary part we're not going to
anytime soon be able to influence uh the
the code of our genetic Legacy but we
can certainly look at the other side of
the balance beam the uh environmental
part and that speaks to your question
about food and I think that clearly the
input of food
in terms of that relationship is vast as
such we look upon food not just in terms
of the macronutrients of protein fat and
carbohydrates or the micronutrients of
minerals and vitamins but we look upon
food as an information cue food is a
powerful indicator to our bodies as to
what we should be expecting right now
and even more importantly what is to
come food tells our bodies to prepare
for food scarcity to prepare for winter
it tells our bodies that now it's time
to stop storing fat and to activate
various Pathways that allow us to burn
fat as fuel and stop making glucose but
that relationship that signaling pathway
is now uh you know facing an accelerator
the likes of which we have never
imagined basically what I'm saying is
we're day in and day out
stimulating a signaling pathway telling
our bodies to prepare for food scarcity
for winter basically but that winter
will never come the eternal Summer
that's right you've also mentioned
fructose what is fructose where does it
live and why are you so Keen to help
people get it out of their diets I don't
think people are keenly aware basically
about anything related to their Foods
when you when you think about it when
you walk around London as I did today
and people are walking and eating
there's no real connection with the
foods that they're eating that the next
bite is being prepared while the the
current bite is being chewed there's
really no connection and we eat what we
are told to eat and what becomes
available to us and uh marketing has
captivated us knowing full well that
each and every person on this planet has
a sweet tooth while you you know rangan
would like to and David bromer would
like to deny it we have as part of our
hard wiring a survival mechanism to
Trend towards sweet sweet tells us two
important things it tells us that the
food is safe
and that the food is good for us because
it tells us winter is coming and
basically allows us to make and store
fat why does it tell us it's safe uh
because basically there is no food on
the planet that is sweet and is toxic at
least in terms of nature nature yeah
sure that's for sure that's a very
interesting Paradox yeah that nowadays
the toxic foods are in fact sweet but it
plays upon us because our hard wiring
says eat that food it is Sweet It Is
safe and it's the right color you know
in nature by and large red foods for
example have traditionally been
threatening nowadays red dye added
things and you know the gummy bears are
certainly perfectly fine seemingly but
we've totally lost our connection
which wasn't something actually humans
ever thought about humans didn't think
about eating particular Foods because it
would prepare their bodies for a type of
stress like food scarcity it just uh
happened as part of our Evolution and
was a powerful a powerful survival
mechanism and and it takes us to a place
of of understanding how our Evolution
has cultivated those behaviors that we
have that make us crave fat salt and
sweet as survival mechanisms those ideas
of adding more salt and fat and sweet to
Manufactured Foods what a concept
manufactured Foods preys upon us it
prays Upon Our hard wiring and makes us
gravitate to to those Foods eat way more
of them than we should and explains in
my opinion
the global explosion in terms of rates
of overweight and obesity and all of the
metabolic Downstream issues that we are
now seeing rule number six is find the
right diet with Dr Mark Hyman do you
think that all inflammation chronic pain
and disease is
can be eliminated from the foods we eat
or is caused by Foods I think besides
having like a car accident or something
yeah there you know I'm a functional
medicine doctor you know run the center
for functional medicine at Cleveland
Clinic and so we look at the root causes
of disease and there are many right
there's environment there's lifestyle
there's genetics all affect these
various systems in your body right so we
always say there's five causes of all
disease based on how they influence your
genetics and combine with your lifestyle
toxins so environmental toxins that's
not your fault that's just the fact we
put 80 000 chemicals in the environment
without testing them we have 3 000 food
items we eat every year as Americans
about three to five pounds of it which
is frightening and you know there are
heavy metals and pesticides everywhere
so we're exposed to a lot of toxins they
make people sick infections which we can
get whether it's viral infections and
bacterial infections Lyme disease tick
infections allergens which are
increasingly common and our food
sensitivities things where your body's
creating an immune response whether it's
gluten or dairy those are big
and then poor diet and stress all of
those are contributing to disease but by
far the biggest cause is food by far and
and it affects I mean we what's amazing
is it's not just like a little bit it's
like you say oh my migraines are my
arthritis or my irritable bowel people
don't connect the dots between how they
feel and the food they're eating and
then when you switch people have
Transformations very quickly yeah you
know they notice it quickly quickly yeah
I mean goes away the weights goes off
all these things yeah I mean I always
say food is medicine it's not just like
a medicine it works faster better and
cheaper than almost any drug I mean we
have people who are off insulin who are
type 2 diabetics within a week wow you
know and and get off all their
medications I mean it was a huge study
just published on a ketogenic diet
intervention for type 2 diabetics and I
don't think ketogenic diets are right
for everybody but in an extreme
situation where your metabolism is so
broken it can help reset things
basically reducing carbs to 30 grams A
Day 70 fat and help in the context of a
healthy plant-rich diet and they were
able to get a hundred percent of the
people in a year over diabetics off of
the main diabetes medication and 94 off
insulin or dramatically lower with an
average weight loss of 30 pounds about
12 percent of body weight and this is
unprecedented in the research because
food if you know how to apply it in the
right way the right dose for the right
person it's the most powerful drug that
I have to spend my life dedicated to the
low-fat diet I haven't been dedicated my
life to paleo veganism I mean I I'm
looking at like what worked and the
other thing I know is that I'm not an
academic well I do research but that's
not how I started I'm a practicing
doctor so what's happened over the years
is the latest thing comes in I try it
see what happens see what happens to
Patient so seeing tens of thousands of
patients doing thousands and thousands
of lab tests over the years same what
happens when people change their diet
and how their biology responds that's
the best laboratory you'll ever see
right I even noticed on myself I was a
vegetarian for 10 years and I see
pictures of myself when I was 28. and I
am so scrawny even though I ate really
healthy I ran five miles a day I did
yoga all the time and I look at myself
now doing far less exercise and I'm far
more muscular and I have more muscle
mass than I did when I was 28 because I
learned how to change my diet and we
know that it's the right kind of high
high fat diet and and adequate protein
actually increases muscle mass wow yeah
I mean I literally just got off the
phone with a friend who says you know I
went on a vegan diet and three days into
it like I can't lift anymore yeah but
then you see some like you know athletes
that are all vegan gain muscle mass and
gain strength in your life well what is
it maybe they're taking steroids I don't
know who knows do you think so you think
living a vegetarian or vegan fully vegan
or vegetarian lifestyle that it's hard
to gain muscle mass I think it's hard
it's it's hard it's not impossible I
mean if you really work at it and really
work out and they are great vegan
athletes out there but there's never
been a historically voluntary vegan
Society ever and when you look at the
no they were never exclusively vegan
right they always had some animal food
dish or something yeah and you know as
Hunter gathers we eat 800 species of
plants so we had a very plant-rich diet
but we also included wild animals when
we can catch them
exactly and so it's it's part of our
evolutionary history and our bodies are
well adapted and the protein in
vegetables is different so for example
there's something called leucine which
is an amino acid that is the rate
limiting amino acid for muscle synthesis
in other words in order to milk bustle
you need this amino acid and it's very
low in plant proteins very high in
animal proteins right so why not just
live a plant-based diet and then have
the supplements you could you could and
I you know I patients through vegans
monks I mean I'm not going to force
people not eat it but it's much harder
to do and you have to know what you're
doing and and I see people over time
initially when they switch from a
processed American diet to A Whole Foods
vegan diet they're going to get so much
better of course yeah but the real issue
is compared to what right right what
really you do is and they and they've
looked at over time in these big studies
looking at
animal and plant proteins and stuff over
time looking at what people do and
there's a there's a vegan that
vegetarian omnivore study which was 245
000 people it was an observational study
but they didn't find any difference in
outcomes um another study 42 country
study looking at Food pattern
consumption over long periods of time
showed actually the people had animal
fat and protein did far better than
people who focus on cereal grains in
their diet less heart disease another
study the pure study just came out
recently 135 000 people that was five
continents I think 18 countries 10 years
and there was actually an improvement
when people had more saturated fat and
more good fats and less cereal grains
and more animal protein rule number
seven is cut sugar with Marxism when I
started researching the Primal endurance
book I started thinking well you know
all of the science continues to show us
that the old Choice was probably a wrong
choice that Reliance on carbohydrates
and that that intent of of managing our
glycogen stores and our muscles was kind
of the wrong approach and maybe we ought
to come at it from the exact opposite
end of the Spectrum which is how do we
become really good at burning fat and in
so doing spare glycogen and in so doing
uh unburden ourselves of having to take
in so much carbohydrate in the form of
pasta and Breads and cereals and rice
and crackers and cookies and all the
other stuff sure and you're you're 62
right yeah right and you're like leaner
than anyone I know so how what's the
most effective way to burn fat and still
be strong yeah of course you know uh as
we said initially in the Primal
blueprint uh and I've said it decades
before the I wrote the parabola print 80
of your body composition is determined
by how you eat so if you there's a
certain way in which you can eat where
you can literally reprogram your genes
to derive most of your energy from your
stored body fat really yes so as opposed
to
um waking up being hungry having
breakfast being hungry at the 10 30
break being hungry for lunch having a
snack in the afternoon having a dinner
and having a snack before you go to bed
which is the sort of standard American
approach like uh even the old
bodybuilders would say don't go more
than three hours without eating or you
will cannibalize your muscle tissue
right that was all based on an
assumption that we had to burn and
carbohydrate had had to access glucose
and glycogen for the muscles to be able
to to continue to work it never
contemplated that we are obligate fat
burners we are born with this amazing
ability to extract calories from stored
body fat and the and the reason that we
don't as we go through life is we
present our you know you're two years
old you're eating cookies and crackers
must peas and all sorts of remember that
yes all that stuff and so your body
learns to depend on on glucose on
carbohydrates as a source of energy it
never really gets to the point where you
force it to burn fat so what we do is we
we shift the diet around
it's not painful you get rid of the
breads the pastas the cereals the
crackers the cookies the candies the
sweetened soft drinks well it does sound
kind of nice it doesn't but but what
you're left with is meat fish foul eggs
nut seeds vegetables a little bit of
fruit
um some starchy tubers like sweet
potatoes things like that those are
great tasting Foods if you eat them
right and and they're real food and
they're real food and you can use butter
and lard and and you can eat bacon on
this on this program and what it does is
it reduces the amount of simple sugars
and carbohydrates you take in and just
sort of forces gently forces your body
to to up regulate all the enzyme systems
that access stored body fat and burn it
and allow you to have more energy
throughout the day without having to eat
so often so the first thing that happens
is your appetite self-regulates so now
you you you get into the space where you
become a good fat burner you start to
melt away you're as hungry because
you're not and you're not as hungry
because you're always carrying around a
meal it's on your thighs it's on your
ass it's on your belly wherever it is
it's you know that's your body becomes
so Adept at accessing those stored
calories it says I don't need to eat I'm
really not that hungry wow yeah and
that's so empowering for so many people
when you you know I was a still love
sugar but I used to be really bad at
Sugar I feel like I have much more under
control but I feel like when you're
eating a lot of candy sweets and sugar
you're never satisfied you just want to
eat more and more and more but that's
until you're sick no exactly I'm full
because I'm sick now yeah I mean stories
of Lamar Odom eating four pounds of
candy four games or whatever yeah but I
mean we are look we're all hired look
where he's at now you know it's like
we're all but sort of by the way sugar
is a very addictive substance so
addictive so
um you know we're all hardwired to seek
out sweet things that's part of that
hunter-gatherer DNA that we all carry
really hasn't changed in in thousands of
years
shift our mind so you the the first way
you do it is is you go from from the
craving which is what you're talking
about like you crave sugar so you eat
sugar and then that just promotes more
craving and it gets you into this sort
of addictive cycle you're actually
producing sort of opiate-like substances
that are that are occupying receptor
sites that are giving you sort of a
feel-good experience so you got to kind
of be willing to to get rid of that so
you get rid of the candies you get rid
of the sweetened beverages the soft
drinks and teas and you get rid of the
carbohydrates that not all carbs but the
the breads that convert to glucose the
bloodstream so rapidly so now you've
lowered your blood your glucose
experience on a daily basis so now the
brain is starting to get you know I
don't need to really get that much
glucose you know I can I can the body is
burning more fat as a result of you
being able to burn fat you used to
create these byproducts called ketones
which the brain loves to burn ketones
and burns them preferentially so you you
need less and less sugar to you know
maintain Clarity throughout the day if
you're if you haven't become fat adapted
and you're a sugar burner which is what
we it's not a derogatory term but we use
it we use a term to describe people who
haven't become fat burners yet they're
sugar burners if you don't eat it's true
if you don't eat for a couple of hours
your blood sugar dips because you
haven't learned how to burn fat yet you
don't know how to access it you can't
take it out of storage and burn it so
now the blood sugar is low the brain
goes I gotta go get some more glucose I
gotta get energy somewhere sugar or
something sugar something so you have
the bagel at you know at 10 30 in the
morning or you have that tastes amazing
well for an hour and then it's no
exactly but then you're hungry again and
that's and that's this vicious cycle so
if we can
um you know take the steps we say it
takes 21 days that's why I have a book
called the 21 day total body
transformation 21 days of this uh
cutting these these sugars and and
starchy um not starchy but uh simple
carbohydrates uh out of your diet and
just focusing on healthy fats and lean
proteins and and uh uh you know and
vegetables right uh you get you your
body gets the message and says I'm not
going to be getting that much glucose
I'm going to learn how to burn fat and
I'm going to do it well damn it and and
then it takes the fat out of your body
fat stores so over time you lose a pound
two pounds a week a new trend towards
your ideal body composition wow so all
of this is a 10 minute long-winded uh
answer to your uh question of how you
know what does it take to you know to
burn fat it doesn't take a lot of
exercise it mostly takes the dietary
shift right yeah you got to do some
exercise you don't have to do anything
but you can choose to do some exercise
it'll help accelerate and it'll help
accelerate it a little bit but most of
it happens as a result it really shifts
you make in your diet absolutely it's
all in the kitchen yep rule number eight
is try intermittent fasting with Dr
Daniel Eamon how much food should the
brain have is it you know is your buddy
our buddy uh Dave asprey talks about
fasting a lot a lot of people are in
this fasting craze if we're not giving
the brain food or nutrients for a day
three days five days does that help the
brain does it reset the brain does it
hurt the brain so intermittent fasting
where you go 12 to 16 hours from dinner
to breakfast or lunch is good they've
actually found your there's a term
called autophagy where your brain begins
to clean up some of the trash so it
works in the brain too not just in the
it works on the brain as as well now I
grew up Roman Catholic and long
suffering was one of the gifts and I
never got that one I'm not a fan of long
suffering yes I'm not doing a marathon
it's like way too much stress for my
brain and I'm not fasting for three days
but I can go 12 hours and I'm like
that's not a big deal and it helps
people lose weight it helps them be
healthy and I come from a family of fat
people my dad you say hey when I would
say that but I have a brother that's 150
pounds overweight despite me loving him
nudging him and
you just have to be thoughtful know your
vulnerability and bright Minds that g is
genetics so know what you're genetically
vulnerable to and you know I have to
work on it right right rule number nine
is engaged in physical activities with
Irwin liqueur you have previously said
that looking fits and being fit
are two different things
they are and and they are not
contradictory you could be fit and look
fit you could also look fit without
really being fit so you have to
understand or to look at Fitness in a
different way than the conventional way
which is mostly looking at uh
the surface of the body the way the body
is shaped which is legitimate it's good
to have a good looking body but it's a
legit expectation
but the way I look at it
is what is it that your body a body can
do
in the real world
in the real life
not what it can do in the gym
um and then what it looks like as a as
an outcome as if that outcome was the
only thing that really matters which is
again it's it's alleged to what a good
looking body but the same time
it's limiting
um
what we have a body for originally is to
be able to move in nature
in in ways that are adaptable to the to
the environment environment that
sometimes that's often changing and
sometimes unpredictable
to be able to operate our body in
effective ways in the real world so an
example of that would be firefighters
they need a body that's functional so
that they can save lives literally
the size of the muscles does not matter
the shape of the body does not matter
are they going to be able to climb up
the stairs or the ladder fast available
to be able to
Sprint to lift or carry or drag a body
to Save a Life to to jump over an
obstacle those are real life movements
and those are natural movements that all
the movements they do are natural
movements the skills jumping running
lifting carrying Etc it is a mindset
it's you you want to have the mindset of
hey my desires to be capable
physically capable in the real world if
the need arises and
it starts with some of the simplest
movements what is it to be capable in
the real world well can you for instance
from a standing position
sit down without using your arms it's a
very simple natural movement get up get
down
and maybe you try to do that and you
find yourself clumsy losing balance
feeling stiff and not able to just do
that that's that's the simplest level of
practical practicality of movement real
world movement now what happens in more
challenging situations maybe
you do need to run fast one day you need
to jump over an obstacle you need to do
that for yourself to get out of uh of
harm maybe to help someone
a neighbor a child your own child your
parent
there are situations of life that are
unexpected they are and it's a good idea
to prepare yourself physically to be
able to again operate your body in the
most effective way in those situations
and even though such situations may
never happen in your life at least the
knowing the awareness that you could
respond properly effectively that your
body is prepared
for these movements
it gives you self-confidence
self-confidence is very important life
if you
believe if you know well yeah that was
to happen I would be helpless that's not
really a good feeling to feel that way
it's good to feel that you're capable
and to know that you're capable so how
do you know you are well you test
yourself at rule number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
get enough good sleep with Dr Tara sword
Bieber rest is basically about sleep
it's not so much about
so overnight sleep it's not as much
about napping or
um just recharging during the day and so
there's no Bell science prize winning
research that
told us more than we ever knew before
about why we need to sleep so the
population Norms we need to sleep seven
to nine hours a night but the way to
know what your number is is if you
naturally wake up at the weekend at the
same time you wake up during the week
then you're getting enough sleep if you
need to lie in or nap or as some of my
clients say I could sleep all weekend if
you let me then you're not getting
enough sleep
um
so that's a good way to figure it out
for yourself so the second strategy is a
good strategy to try and catch up on
sleep on the weekend no so if you need
to if you need to lie in or nap or you
know go to bed early or just sleep a lot
at the weekend because that means that
you're not getting enough sleep
um you need to rectify you know what's
happening during the week so that it's
more evened out but also because if you
miss you know one night's good sleep or
even one night's complete sleep here and
there that's not so bad but if you go
for four nights or more and accumulate
what's called a sleep debt then you
can't actually do anything to make up
for that so
um one of the things that I so I was
talking to Joel our co-founder
um about a really nice way to talk about
sleep which is
you can never be in credit with sleep
you can only be okay or in debt
so you know it's important to not say I
went on holiday and slept 15 hours a
night so now I can you know work all
hours and and neglect my sleep kind of
thing
um
so during that seven to nine hours in
bed
um there's an eight hour cleansing
process that occurs overnight which is
absolutely vital to cleaning out the
toxins that build up during the day and
these are mainly from
stress alcohol
some processed or smoked foods which
we'll go into later and just the you
know just the general metabolism of the
body and particularly as we age
so what we've seen is that this is a
very active flushing out of toxins it's
not a passive trickling of fluid
throughout the brain and spinal cord
overnight and that the actual toxins
that are being flushed out are amyloid
um plaques and Tangles and Tau proteins
which are exactly the pathology that we
see in diseases of Aging like
Parkinson's and Alzheimer's
so if you chronically disrupt that
process then the potential implications
for the age of onset of a dementia-like
disease
um is that you're bringing that forward
so
you know our brains are declining
through our age in ways that aren't
noticeable to our day-to-day function
but when it hits a certain threshold
like a Tipping Point of neurons that
have been destroyed you would start to
see cognitive deficits like memory
problems and um if you're not sleeping
sufficient length and quality throughout
most of your life then that Tipping
Point can come earlier
right now we're on a mission to
transform the health and well-being of
our society including our world family
but specifically here in the United
States right now recent estimates show
that diet related chronic diseases cost
the United States economy a staggering
one trillion dollars each and every year
now this isn't uniquely a United States
issue diet related diseases have become
a global issue in fact a massive
meta-analysis recently published in the
Lancet titled health effects of dietary
risk in 195 countries examine the links
between poor diet and the skyrocketing
rates of chronic diseases in our world
today the scientists determined that
poor diet kills 11 million people
around the world every year
the researchers stated quote our
findings show that sub-optimal diet is
responsible for more deaths than any
other risks globally
highlighting the urgent need for
improving human diet across Nations
unquote the researchers stated that poor
diet is responsible for more deaths than
any other issue around the world
but what are we doing about it
processed food manufacturers with the
assistance of government regulations
that allow them to perform as they do in
our Societies in our communities are
flooding our communities
flooding store shelves with
disease-causing Foods creating an
atmosphere where we're inundated we're
surrounded by the very foods that cause
the diseases that again this is the
number one risk for death globally is
from these low quality foods
now today we're experiencing an
interesting phenomena where more people
are dying from the over consumption of
these foods and from not getting enough
food to eat
right there's been a change that's
happened in our society just within the
last couple of generations where we're
dying from excess rather than not enough
but again it's the quality of the food
that matters more than anything and also
understanding the industries and
entities that are leveraging this that
are taking advantage of this and again
providing our families with really low
quality food and making that normalized
because the truth is food can be a
powerful tool for healing and for
happiness
but it can also be a powerful weapon for
degradation and disease
it really depends on what we're eating
but today's episode is looking at
something very interesting
it's looking at stacking conditions in
our favor to make healthier choices
automatic because as mentioned we're
inundated often surrounded by low
quality choices
but we're going to address a practical
lifestyle intervention that all of us
can make right now at this very moment
and create a layer of protection against
diet related diseases for our families
because the truth is we might be under
the illusion that we're making the
choices of what we eat by ourselves
right we're like I'm a big boy I'm a big
girl I make my own choices we might be
under the illusion that that's taking
place
but the reality is and as the research
clearly indicates our environment
and more interestingly what you're going
to learn today
whom we're eating with
has a huge impact on our diet and health
outcomes our thoughts our beliefs our
actions how we associate with the world
around us is heavily influenced by our
environment again our environment and
the people within that environment and
we've quickly shifted from a species
that prepared and ate food together for
thousands upon thousands of years to
today frequently eating in isolation
with processed foods and mind-numbing
media
what's the real impact of this shift
that's taking place just within the last
couple of generations
did eating together actually help
protect human health in some way
well several studies have now
demonstrated how much the simple Act of
eating together as a family can
influence the outcomes of our food
choices for instance researchers at
Harvard University recently uncovered
that people who consistently eat dinner
with their families frequently consumed
more fruits and vegetables and
significantly less processed food and
soda
their data analysis also showed that
increased frequency of family dinner
was also associated with higher intakes
of several key nutrients that support
human health and defend the body against
numerous diet related diseases
specifically eating together as a family
increased the consumption of calcium of
iron of B vitamins vitamin C vitamin E
lowered the glycemic load of the food
that they were eating and also lowered
the intake of trans fats
crazy is that that the simple Act of
eating together as a family
has all of these benefits as far as what
we're taking in in a beneficial fashion
and what we're avoiding from a
detrimental perspective who knew that
the conditions in which we eat and
specifically the people that we're
eating with could have such a profound
impact on what we're actually eating I
know that I didn't
in the environment that I grew up in I
had no idea that this was even a thing
but it makes sense if we're looking at
human biology and how we evolved as a
species and if we're constantly trying
to Target the food choices themselves
telling people don't eat that stuff
that's bad shame shame shame I know your
name don't eat that right eat these
things if we're constantly trying to
Target the food choices themselves
without addressing the environment and
the family culture around eating then
we're really missing the point because
this is more of a foundational component
that's determining the food choices
rather than trying to treat the symptom
of the food Choice itself as the data
indicates having a family ritual of
eating together makes it easier to eat
better things
according to data publishing the Journal
of the American Medical Association
Network and the journal Pediatrics
Children and adolescents are at
vulnerable stages for the development of
environment fostered obesity
their data revealed that children and
young adults who share family meals
three or more times per week
are more likely to be in a healthy
weight range and have a healthier diet
and eating pattern than those who share
fewer than three family meals together
additionally and this is incredibly
important as well these children were
far less likely to engage in disordered
eating
right this is another epidemic that
isn't getting a lot of press
which is the rampant increase in
disordered eating amongst our children
this is one of those insulators against
these Behavior patterns is eating
together more often as a family now
this three meals per week together as a
family appears to be the minimum
effective dose to create this insulation
because you made it this
High want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
more incredible Andrew huberman
motivation check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I'm gonna say again I would
absolutely anchor my physiology with
morning sunlight viewing you know what's
special about morning sunlight there's a
group at the University of Washington
and they've discovered